This is a really high value, meaning that the relationship between miles and
ticket price is very strong. R squared is about 0.83 which means that 83% of
the differences in cost is due to the differences in miles traveled. Now we
want to find the equation for our line of best fit. Remember that the generic
form is y equals bx plus a or a plus bx, doesn't matter. Where b is our slope
and a is our y intercept. You learned before that the slope is equal to
Pearson's R times the ratio of the standard deviations. We already found R. Our
next step is to find the standard deviation for the y values. And the standard
deviation for the X values. Remember that since these are the sample standard
deviations, we have to use the corrected standard deviation, dividing by n
minus 1.